make way for Rick Neuheisel CBS sports
analyst former college head coach and he
was on the set in Tuscaloosa LSU in
Alabama I was a wild scene Rick and I
had an NFL scout telling me who was at
the game he said you think that these
guys are fast on TV he said in person
would blow your mind how much talent was
out there on the field on Saturday it
was off the charts Stan it is off the
charts I think the two winning relay
teams in the SEC attract meet were both
on display the receiver position there's
at least seven of those guys that are
going to play in the NFL and the second
half was taken over by the two running
backs
we knew the quarterbacks were really
good and went to a kind of got
comfortable there in the second half he
put on a show that touchdown pass on
fourth down to Judy that like goal line
come back out that was awesome throw but
but this kid burrow Dan when Alabama got
this game to one score they did it twice
in in this in the fourth quarter borough
and in those two drives which both ended
in touchdowns goes 912 for 106 and has
two carries for another 30 some-odd
yards deck that guy said it before is
Tom Bray he is going to be a remarkable
NFL player ok what do you see because I
used to be a quarterbacks coach you
played the position so I trust your
assessment as much as anybody but I I
loved his demeanor because I don't know
if he's up 14 or down 14 and I said
that's a great attribute to have at that
position it does he have all of the
other things that you want in what
you're saying he could turn out to be a
great NFL quarterback he's got great
accuracy and there were maybe two or
three throws in the entire game that I
think he wants back he's got a great
sense of anticipation that's the thing
you're looking for most when you're
making the transit transition from
college to Pro because spaces don't stay
open as much as they do at the
collegiate level you know they're open
but they don't stay open so you have to
anticipate he has
he has that ability his relationship
with Jamar chase who almost almost
always lines up into the boundary kind
of reminds me of Manning and and Reggie
Wayne remember Reggie Wayne and Marvin
Harrison always Wayne was to the left
Harrison was to the right and whenever
those guys got in the boundary they just
knew how to throw each other open it was
remarkable and that's what he has with
that kid and then he has this gunslinger
type mentality that he doesn't care what
the score is as you point out and maybe
as important or more importantly that
his play colors don't care if it's 14 ad
or 14 down in these situations where
most the conventional school of thought
is hey let's just get see if we can turn
out some clock here make some first
downs they go right back to whipping it
around the yard they did it against
Texas earlier in the year and resulted
in a 31 for 39 performance and here he
goes again this guy is unique he really
is and his ability to stay alive in the
pocket extend plays how many times did
he shut off a Crimson Tide defender in
this game and being on the field and
watching it you realize just how strong
he is he's completing 79% of his passes
Rick the this the NCAA record is 76 that
was Colt McCoy in that epic year for
Texas and he goes 32 of 42 against
Auburn who I think has the best defense
in the country
with maybe this side of Ohio State and
he goes 32 or 42 in that game and his
percentage Falls he's a remarkable
player he's got remarkable weapons
around him and that little bowling ball
with legs Clyde Edwards he'll air and
they show unto himself it was really
really fun to be a part of that scene
all right you are running the Bengals
you're on the clock with the first pick
overall go go Burl's coming back to Ohio
in and I'm going to tell you that New
Orleans Saints are going to fight them
for the pick they're they're going to
try to figure out a way to get up into
that situation to have the next answer
for where Drew Brees retires at you know
age 63 but
the bottom line is this guy to me has
all the things that you like dan this is
a guy that on his recruiting trip to LSU
when he was transferring Ohio State
walked out and the the Tiger team was
working out they were running wind
sprints
he asked for shorts and tennis shoes so
that he could go run with the team this
is that kind of leader this is that kind
of cachet
he's not over his skis you know into it
for the fame he just likes being on this
team and it just has Brady written all
over it but maybe a little bit better
athlete than tom is in terms of escaping
the pressure I haven't heard you this
deeply in love in a long time this is a
man-crush there's no question about it I
this guy I keep looking for holes in his
game you know knowing that I was going
to be down there I watched a bunch of
tape this guy makes play after play
after play that first throw he threw to
damar chase down the sideline was
absolutely a thing of beauty it was the
ball was never had a ounce of wiggle in
it
it was perfectly thrown over the outside
shoulder only chase could make the play
and it was that kind of afternoon it
really was fun to watch do we know to a
at the next level because it felt like
at the beginning of the Earl tanking for
two and I said you know we we fall in
love early and then all of a sudden and
we've done this you know Josh Rosen
Christian Hackenberg you know to is a
fabulous player and played hurt and
played well but that transition yeah are
you are you sold on to of being a
starter in the NFL I think to his
greatest asset is his fearlessness he
has this ability that just rise into the
deal I remember the national
championship game where but he learned
the name Tunga by llola right when he
came in and he threw an interception to
a receiver that was downfield blocking I
mean it wasn't even a pass play and he
throws a pick and then he goes over and
puts his arm around that five foot six
general over there that had a little
scowl on his face don't worry coach hang
loose brah it's like holy smokes who is
this guy right but I do think when I
look just at him carefully that he's
he his anticipation skills are not quite
the same other than the RPO world where
it's kind of a timing deal and give LSU
credit they took away all those slants
in this game which is why to his numbers
we're not 70 percent and above they were
more in the 50 percent range I think two
would benefit staying another year I
know he won't I think two could really
get better as a drop-back passer babe
they'll have Waddell back maybe rug
stays and he could have another monster
year with Alabama and really get good
Sarkisian had been at the NFL I think he
could really benefit from another year
because I think right now he's the
fourth quarterback in this draft after
burrow and the two kids from the
northwest we're talking to Rick
Neuheisel joining us Continental Tire
coaches corner do Justin Herbert make
the right decision staying in Oregon
well it seems as if he did I mean he's
having a blast and remember he's from
Eugene he grew up there so for his
family this is just the dream come true
that he's getting to enjoy this and
especially the way they played against
SC this last time out Oregon is a
complete team at Andy Avalos the defense
coordinator came over from Boise State I
think has that defense playing as
synchronized as the defense can play and
so all the pieces are coming together
and I know he's having a blast like Lane
remember when liner decided to stay it
was because he's enjoying it and money
wasn't you know something that had to be
so critical for life changing for that
family so to me this is was a good
decision and hopefully the ride
continues for him it's gonna get a
little delicate at USC it feels like
clay Helton no matter what he does is
probably not gonna keep that job new
athletic director coming in but if you
have the athletic directors who asked if
they could bring in Urban Meyer
reportedly and then so who wins that tug
of war the the new president at USC or
the new athletic director who may want
to opt for Urban Meyer well it's a great
question I agree with you I think it's a
fait accompli that that clay ends up on
the outside looking in which is a shame
because he keeps battling his nail op
and that team that team won't quit on
him they just keep playing hard that was
a
gadi win in the desert against the
devils this last weekend but I think
they're going to make a move what was
disappointing if you're an SC fan or a
pac-12 fan is that all that laundry got
aired publicly yeah before the
announcement of Mike bonus B as the
court as the new athletic director
I think Urban Meyer's the right guy
there I think
Urban Meyer not only fixes SC and gets
national recruiting back in instead I
think Urban Meyer is also a shot in the
arm for the pac-12 but it seems as if
Carol L fault has the new president is
already you know said that that's not
what she has in mind maybe she needs to
be more convinced of the details of what
took place at at Ohio State rather than
just the optics we'll wait and see who
wins that tug of war but there's got to
be a lot of people at USC that are
hoping for Urban Meyer but you know who
else they might put on their list that
jambalaya sounding guy down there in the
Bayou he had some time there at SC coach
oh yeah I mean shoot he would have
crawled on his hands and knees for that
job and would you think it's easier to
win a national championship from from
USC playing that UCLA Bruins or the
Alabama Crimson Tide especially after he
got caught on tape saying all those
questions yeah sir best that he's
explaining to do as they say in this out
they already got t-shirts made up of
what is it roll tide bleep you exactly
oh my god what a great journey for a
toes your up I mean this is a guy that
called Tommy Tuberville and drove from
Arkansas to Miami in one night to get I
think a strength coach job with Dennis
Erickson that parlayed into a defensive
line job that I mean he's been regarded
as one of the great recruiters around
the country he's the interim coach at
USC when Lane Kiffin gets the tarmac
treatment and and and he his first press
conference what are you done differently
says I gave the boys cookies cookies I'm
going well this is genius right and I
mean he was broken
harder when they decided to go with Sark
such to the point that he left I said he
came up for wink four weeks of an
infomercial and clay Helton got to be
the interim coach when they beat that
Fresno State team with Derek Carr now
he's at LSU and he gets another interim
job they realized they can't beat Texas
in this spend a thong that was going to
be for Tom Herman he gets this job and
what a job he's done it's it's it's a
movie stuff but IDO and enjoyed Saturday
night but I would not rule him out and
that SC sweepstakes I'd also put James
Franklin's name in there great to talk
to you bud as always we appreciate your
insights thank you Rick no hay one of
these we need a new song from you one of
these days oh it's time after seeing
some of these officials calls I got one
in mine whoo I like that well let Fritzi
know when you're ready you know cuz
we're we're ready for a new recording
from Rick new logic you got it baby hi
Rick Neuheisel CBS sports college
football analyst he used to come up with
some great songs and you'd have his
guitar and really well thought out
Continental Tire coaches corner for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]